oh
i know
so uh
obviously uh
representative major
is not here
um
on easter he
he had a tumble
um
down three there was three steps he fell
uh he made it to session
uh the last session last week
but at lunch break it took him about 15
minutes to walk from
the state house to here back here uh he
says pat i gotta go he headed to leahy
um where they had him there for nine
hours
and uh they said i mean he's having
trouble walking now so
um he won't be around this week and
we'll just take it week by week just so
you know
so i i'm going to be chairing these two
bills
and
in the calendar they're called work
sessions the clerk
paul smith
suggested we we put them in the calendar
that way they're technically hearings
but
but we're calling on work sessions so
so
and we're we're going to take 313
first and then uh and then uh 3
79 second
so
uh 313
uh past 17 nothing out of the edna
committee and passed on a voice vote
on the floor
and uh
um fortunately we have carol mcguire's
is here
uh chair of edna to explain
uh what was done in 313 when it when it
came over from the senate
it had had another section in it
that was
uh amended out
and that
wound up in
in
and they put it into
senate bill 330
and
reps and mcguire if you can't help us
out the history of this i think it goes
back to senate bill 38 last session
58 last session and what happened i
don't know about where it started last
year but since the oplc has started
and what was it was created
and it had the authority to set fees we
have been piece by piece cleaning up
section 30
with where all the boards originally had
the authority to set fees and in many
cases the fees were in statute
so we have been
repeatedly going through
every time we deal with the board we
check that the fee authority is correct
that is they don't set the fee they just
collect it with their applications
usually
and
so it's always a conflict because the
oplc has authority to set fees for all
the boards under its purview
but meanwhile other boards
still have in statute their own fees
which are
therefore in conflict so 313 is this
year's version of how to fix that
um
so it listed
as it came to edna
it had
starting on page two a nice long
suggestion list of various fees
that were being deleted and boards that
were
whose statute was being amended to talk
about the fee set by the oplc rather
than by themselves
and edna agrees with that in general yes
it's on
because we're streamed
um
could you the first time you use a set
of initials
say what it is
certainly thank you and just for the
record i'm carol mcguire
merrimack district 29 which is
allenstown epsom and pittsfield and i'm
the chair of the house edna committee i
also
did the work on this particular bill in
committee
i will say that due to excellent
scheduling on the part of everybody
we got the bill on
wednesday afternoon heard at the
heard it the following friday and
executed on tuesday so we did not give
it our usual thorough combing
we did verify that we agreed with all of
the sections that it contained we didn't
have the time to go and add additional
sections that might also have that same
situation so we
this is
relatively accurate but it is not
complete as you can see from the
amendment representative alby is
bringing forward
we looked at the study
committee and while we don't disagree
with the need to look at the fees and
how they're set
we thought it would make more sense to
combine it with the study committee in
senate bill 330 which was about the
operations of the oplc because the study
committee
excuse me because the fees are set in
order to cover costs so if you don't
look at what you're doing
as an operation you don't know how much
to charge
the usual thing for the boards is to
keep charging what they've been charging
which means that some of the boards
accountancy is one i know
because they're the first one in the in
the packet i get
they have not two extreme fees but
they're an extremely well-behaved board
that is administered very cheaply and
they provide us every year
there are other boards where the fees
don't even cover their costs let alone
a little extra for on
emergencies
so we need to look at how things are run
and then consider how the fees are
collect are set um also it looked from
the definition of who was going to be on
those those committees that i know
at least one of the persons who would be
logically appointed to both of them and
i couldn't see doing that
so uh
we deleted the study committee from
senate bill 313
the version that karen was handing out
is the version as amended by the senate
so the version as amended by the house
deletes page one and page two up to line
nine ten
representative almi has an amendment
that i'm sure she'll talk about
which i support what it does is it
continues establishing
that the
board doesn't set the fees for a number
of different boards that we haven't had
we didn't have the time to look into
so
there's we have no objection about it
and in fact support cleaning up as many
statutes as we can at one time
and i will answer any questions
um
so does the 125 rule still apply to this
yes the oplc has a requirement that the
total fees minus total expense that the
total fees are 125 percent of total
expenses right and they're trying to
allocate it to the individual boards as
well
but
some of the boards are either so tiny or
so
swingy i mean the board of of real
estate people real estate brokers
has when real estate is big they've got
hundreds of new new licensees and they
bring in more fees when the market
collapses they barely cover their cost
so you have to to look at it as an
overall deal rather than
expecting every single board to hit it
125 percent every year okay thank you
well representative has a question
thank you very much
thank you representative mcguire uh a
couple of questions
um
in in the in the amended version that
you that you work on are the findings
included the first paragraph that would
be on this
bill we have in front of us lines one
through nine
on page
one
i'm afraid i don't remember okay
um
follow follow-up
yes
representative mcguire
ways and means is charged with a full
evaluation of fees and supplicability
the revenue to the state
am i mistaken but you're chain taking it
out of the ways and means
and putting it out to an administrative
body to set a fee
i'm sorry you're taking it away from
ways and means
the setting of a fee
and then moving it to an administrative
body
representative hollery the
different boards have been setting their
own fees for years
decades as far as i know they decide
what their
their expenses are they develop the fees
they don't normally come to you
with their new fees
they might
in many cases they set their fees in
rule and they're brought before jail car
and at least one member of this
committee is also a member of jail car
in fact there's two usually
um so we look at
the
jail car as your delegate looks at the
total fees
uh thank you
one of the chair yeah
the question
we've been working with a lot of
different fees over the last several
years to move them into law
i know i that's that's the thing when we
saw this
something happened a couple of years ago
there was a bill passed
that last year i did it was a 58
was it the house
yeah i think it's 58. um i don't know if
it's a senate bill i think it was a
senate bill it probably was the senate
bill yes it was it was gaida and
something else so
that changed all of that we weren't
aware of it
it just must have just been on consent
calendar or something we we didn't
realize that because well i i know
representative almi and myself
maybe six or seven years ago
spent a lot of time
trying to equalize and those have been
around
all these making sure they were within
the 125 and all of that
and we didn't we didn't learn about this
change and now now it's in the hands of
it's who's it in the hands of
right now the oplc has the authority to
set the fees for all the boards
under their purview and those those
rules are those fees are set in rules
right not in statute
if you wish to change that decision
i i think it would make sense to at
least wait to figure have them fig the
study committee completed because
we don't know how the operation works
and
we have
some boards that think it's everything's
peachy keen
except their fees are too high
and there are others that say it's a
total mess and we can't get done what we
need to get done
so i'm i want the study committee in
senate bill 330 is looking at the
overall operations
and
i think that's necessary before you try
and claw back the fee authority and so
just and i was over yesterday to talk to
you and uh i requested that we have two
two members
um from ways and means included i'm
assuming that happened i'm afraid it
didn't we were on our fifth iteration of
the amendment to senate bill 330 by the
time we got finished at six o'clock last
night and we didn't want to go another
round to include ways and means it has
three at the moment it has three house
members one of whom is not
whose alliance is not us or his back is
whose committee is not assigned and we
recommended that that should be from
ways and means
but that doesn't does it say that and
it didn't say that does it say that in
the amendment no
would you mind if we do a floor
amendment to include ways of means
not at all we we thought ways and means
was another logical committee to have
people there we did want to have
edna because we deal with licensing and
health and human services because so
many of the licenses we and the
operations the roplc are in the health
sector
and those are always the most
problematical ones
okay thank you representative oh well
let representative romney have
transfers
okay i uh first i just wanted to point
out that
under the rules of the house this
committee is supposed to deal with fees
and
that's why
um
representative abrami and i spent
uh
about four months
over a summer working with all of the
medical and health groups that
boards and commissions that
other than the big ones the doctors and
the nurses
on
that
to try and bring all of their fees into
some kind of consolidated order and that
in turn led to
changing the entire olpc so that yes i i
worked with the results of your
study and
implemented putting a large number of
fees into statute particularly for the
smaller boards
and we did that um
some years ago yeah and
i think
it is a question of whether we want to
have the fees in statute or rule
and
at the moment it's the pendulum has
swung to put them into role
i personally think statute is more
appropriate for many of them but
i keep getting outvoted
that's interesting
thank you
on
we
one of the problems with jail car
handling the fees is that if there isn't
a clear definition in
in statute of what the fee is for
how much it
you you can't really decide how much it
should be
and i know this has been discussed in
jail car because i know representative
hatch keeps bringing it up
but he used to be on ways and means
uh yes
so
so that that is a long-term kind of
consideration that we're worried about
the the thing is is how granular do you
want to be with the fees
does you know do you want every single
board to maintain 125
every year well
good luck
it's going to be a constant moving
target if you want to have the
the all the boards together or some
subset of boards to do 125 every year
you've got a better chance if you want
to have all the boards average 125
percent over a biennium
that's probably much easier
i wanted to ask you about one odd man
out yes in which is the manufactured
housing board
which a group of us has been trying to
add another board to that is the same
kind of thing
and it was never set up with the ability
to pay for itself
because trailer park
tenants don't have much money and so
they pay
pay a fee to make a complaint but
um it doesn't end up paying for squat
so
uh that's our choice how yeah how
how you handle that it wasn't i think it
was originally sort of assigned to the
predecessor of olpc
but
and it makes a lot of administrative
sense efficiency
uh considerations
to leave it there but how do you how are
you handling that one
uh i'm afraid i have no idea
maybe it's inside of the 25 of 125
well it could well be i mean the
when uh
as i understood it some years ago 125
was meant for the 100 to cover their
basic expenses the 25 percent to cover
either things that don't happen every
year like hiring a rule writer to update
your rules or a complex investigation
where you needed more attorneys or
something like that
that was my understanding of why 125
is we
well this goes back quite a long way
when we were getting trained by the
legislative assistant
about this stuff but that the
was considered to be an allowable amount
by
certain courts
to add on for the general expenses of
the state apparatus to help that
particular
fund
that too
representative bursting and then
number thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking taking my question
representative mcguire
back to the committee i'm a little
confused because you had
said you wanted one member to be from
hhs
also
ways and means wants to be represented
but as the bill reads now there's three
members from the house two of which are
from edna no excuse me representative
bernstein you are looking at the version
of 313 as amended by the senate you are
not looking at house bill 330 as amended
by the house which is not yet available
we haven't passed it
that has a
a committee of four members at the
moment one senator one person from edna
one representative from edna one
representative from hhs and an
unspecified representative which we
recommend should be from ways and means
if you put out a floor amendment to add
a and a ways and means member
specifically or two of them we'd be
happy we're perfectly okay with that
we
as i said we were we were chasing
amendments all day yesterday i got it i
appreciate the clarification thank you
representative schaumburg
thank you mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question i guess
what i'm looking for
i need a clear understanding of of
what these organizations these boards
do do they not have a set cost every
year of
is it to pay for secretaries they do
the what the boards do is that every
year they license some number of
professionals
they take new applicants and renewals
some of them honest on a
cycle and others you know on the on your
birthday month or a year after whatever
they it varies by board
they hear
complaints
and they
decide on discipline
for their members they also
uh make sure their rules are correct and
up to date and deal with things like
applicants that don't quite
don't seem to quite meet the the
requirements
follow-up mr chair
my question really is
they must have some idea of what their
operation is going to cost for that year
correct yes
and
does anyone else see that
in the eda or ways and means or
it's a part of the budget
the overall most of these administrative
tax well the boards are now under oplc
which means that they're in the budget
for a plc which covers the
secretarial staff
a couple of investigators
the
investigators a hearing officer
thing things like paper things like that
yeah it's
like as i said the
the larger boards are steadier and the
smaller ones are more erratic
represent ruler again
and and one thing that the oplc is
trying to do
is to consolidate things like
secretarial services and license
applications
so that they that instead of having one
person per board they have specialists
and licenses who will deal with the
routine ones and forward the complicated
ones to the boards
representative murphy actually my
friends
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
representative taking my question
i was trying to compare the um
house version amended and then the
senate one and
my question is just where did the fees
go and is it continually evolving from
the general fund into now the
uh
as as of when we created the oplc it has
a a fund for
all of its operations
that
i'm i believe has some lapse
requirements in the general fund but in
general we don't want to lapse a great
deal
from the license fees which is their
main source of income we wanted to
make sure
excuse me that they cover
picture uh
yeah
and just
so does that mean with each iteration
that you you mentioned you're trying to
clean up each board and
that they go into that fund versus the
general fund that was previously
referenced in i believe the statutory
change that gave the oplc
the right to
charge all fees also included their fund
and
said all board fees go into this fund
but i
i admit i don't know for exactly sure
thank you
what was that really
um thank you mr chair um
just reviewing the um
house modified version
you're correct it begins with the
setting of the fees on line 10
acupuncture piece
so the finding section is not included
but it seems to me that the findings
section sets the reasoning for
this particular
structure
so my question is would you be adverse
to
an amendment that reinserted
um
the general no they i believe they are
all all correct we did take all of the
charges for the study committee and add
them to the other study committee we did
that
but you can't see that here
okay yeah see we're mr chair the issue
is
we don't have access to sp 330
which is setting up the study committee
right and we're not on that study
committee because of what you know well
we're going to we're going to we're
going to do a floor member to uh
ways and means on that yeah um but in
that case i won't i'll take it off
consent
make it easier for you okay thanks thank
you
uh the the
the other point would be that we need
some justification as to the purpose of
that plus the work that you and um
you and representative almi did
um and matter of fact the whole
committee was involved in that uh one
degree or another in in
reviewing these fees we found that there
were a lot of
they're just all over the place well it
is
it is but it's also
no two boards are created equal well
yeah
and that that some of them have uh
oversight some of them have uh
they uh ways of uh if there's wrongdoing
by members of their board they they have
they all have that authority they have
okay
so
so but again that they're all a little
different you know
the other thing representative hillary
is that i know when
we've talked with various boards there
is a large resistance to making
significant changes in their fees a lot
of the the people that a lot of the
licensees seem to prefer to say fine
it's 300
every two years i know that's too much
but i'd rather not have it go down to
250 and then back up to 350.
so
i understand that and then i think
everybody on on
this committee understands that as well
the uh issue is however when you uh
relegate setting fees to an
administrative body
administrative bodies have a tendency to
grow
no
i'm shocked that you say that
and you're winning to here's your
winnings yes that's a very good seat
in casablanca but um
so
getting it back into
a more difficult
process uh setting fees by rule
is not
in any way shape or form good
governments but setting up a centralized
licensing bureau as opposed to 50
different or 150 different
boards for each one
makes a great deal of sense we we just
need to be very careful on that sir
i don't object to you to the idea that
ways and means should be setting its
fees
or as part you know but
at the moment that's not what the law
says
all right so so back to the back to this
uh
study
uh joint study committee with the senate
uh
i i it seems like it's
what the goal there is to give some
parameters
for which the
office of professional licensure and
certification
should
do its fee setting by some guidance
correct
is that part of this yes we want to see
how they're looking at how they allocate
fees between boards because some
obviously some costs are going to be
allocated
okay so
um i had recommended
two seats but then i i uh offer ways of
means to be on there because that's kind
of what we do we look at those kind of
things
and i thought it very appropriate and
representative romney and i discussed
that and
we'd like to have one republican one
democrat on it that's i have no
objection to that
but as i said we just kind of ran out of
time last night
but i i saw when i i i i increased your
numbers to two as well i took the
liberty
thank you representatives to make it
proportional to
your committee and and our committee
thank you so much
[Laughter]
you can't get volunteers to do that
i could keep it at one
thank you no that's fine you ha you have
that if you're expanding the size of the
committee then
i don't have too much of an objection
but we'll see
all right so
well i want you to agree because i on
the floor i don't want i don't want you
getting up i'm certainly not going to
fight you on the floor that's for sure
okay
all right
thank you
um represent of ames
okay i just wanted to respond to uh
the
concern expressed by representative ur
about the uh find the what are they
called findings
uh section
i think what you've done
as i understand it is to remove the
findings
and the
committee
and that makes sense to me because i
think the findings were the predicate
for the
study committee um and with the removal
of those two sections what we're left is
with
what i would call a cleanup bill uh
a fix-it kind of thing
which uh
representative amy
has
found one more fix that needs to be
added to that and that's good um
but i don't think representative ulri
that we need the findings because
they're not really
a part of what we've ended up with here
it's a it's a simpler bill and uh for
the findings and all the discussion that
goes into
that
we've got a separate bill that's coming
to the floor of the house
that we'll be dealing with uh in terms
of membership of committee
uh
when it comes so i i think
this is a simple bill we've got here and
uh
we've got an add-on we haven't talked
about but uh
it seems uncontroversial so
that's the way i see it
thank you representative ames i agree
with you as as amanda it's simply
cleanup of the statutory language that
conflicts with other statutory languages
right
given that
over the last year or so there have been
changes
we kind of really weren't that aware of
that so basically
yes the cleanup would be needed to
comply with
the new statutes we'd have to clean this
up
and
so basically that's what we're going to
be doing
but on the other hand we want to make
sure we're representing on that
committee
to
uh at least be at the table when this
this issue is being discussed
about putting some guardrails around
how how the fees will be set in the
future by the
office of professional licensure and
certification
that's helped that will be very much
appreciated okay
any other questions
okay
just one one comment uh
i'm i've been on for quite a while a
four-person
study committee long-term study
committee and uh
it's an awful number a what awful number
oh you need three for a quorum so if two
people can't be there that day you can't
meet
uh
thank you for that information we'll uh
in that case this floor amendment will
be useful
okay
any other questions of representative
mcguire
saying none thank you very much for
your attentiveness and
insights into what happened here okay
so
is the is the amendment ready yet
yes it turns out that they were more
efficient than i was
oh
do you want to hand something
i think what we would like to do is to
um
to
exec this bill now before we go move on
to the next bill
and um
oh by the way i um
i forgot we do have one replacement
that's
representative
to check
and who are you replacing uh
jane again okay thank you
so okay why don't we do it this way why
don't we why don't we just have a
discussion
technically it is a work session not a
hearing
uh that's the way the clerk wanted us to
set this up uh given the short notice of
everything
uh the clerk paul smith
so
um
let's when we start with the amendment
susan and just explain what what this
does and then
okay um
i was freaked out a little by this
because my version went through every
single one of
the boards that
just by doing a search for fee
on the areas that they'd been working in
uh
got
on didn't get changed the way they got
changed elsewhere
so all of that that this
does
and carol's looked at it now uh
represented maguire uh
is
on for
system evaluators which they did touch
but
they forgot to remove the late fees from
permission to be set
that's the first
section in here 31
and then 32 is a combination of the
engineers architects geologists
landscape architects and home inspectors
all of whom
had their fees removed elsewhere but not
in the rule-making sections
so it
it changes estab registration fees
established by the board to
registration fee established by the
office of professional licensure and
certification which is the executive
director in the case of
the office
and
on
she's terrific but she she's been there
i think two years
well she's been there three years she
was hiding in the office figuring out
what was wrong with it for a year and
then she was promoted to take it over
and she really is terrific but
apparently um there's a certain amount
of adjustment going on as they change
this into a more efficient organization
the
the opposite of efficient unfortunately
is new hampshire tradition which i value
a great deal which allows
the professions to
set up their own boards on their own
terms
and oversee their own members con
conduct
so
it's a balancing act that
always requires a little bit of pain on
both sides
but this is all this amendment does it
adds it on to
what was left of 313
which
is taking out references that they had
not noticed last year when they took out
a lot of the references and we didn't
see that bill at all
so
i want to thank you representative army
for uh the homework he did
in scrubbing this and finding those
other references that should have been
taken out represented southwest yes
thank you i think this is a great
amendment it clarifies and simplifies
win-win basically
that was drafting would you like it to
be moved
uh this one any other discussion
okay why don't we go through the uh
process we we usually do the motion on
the bill and then first and then then we
have the motion on the
i'd like representative almighty to make
the motion on if you don't mind because
we have to get these blurbs written
really quick so oh yeah
so we're going to go into executive
session
that's a weird game i
know so because look at pizza meat with
it
it's amazing it's not our heads so uh
i i
move
that uh i move out to pass on senate
bill 313 and would like to
make an amendment
okay anybody second that motion
representative uhlery went first so
okay um
and what's the amendment please
the amendment
is
h
on
and i move out to pass on that
okay
okay um
do you want to speak to that or do you
think we've explained it
i think we've explained it okay
okay
so we could probably take a hand vote on
the amendment so all in favor of uh
accepting this amendment raise your hand
i think we're unanimous you just want to
do a head count on that to see what we
got
no do you keep your hands down but it's
going to kind of resent
oh how many of us are there
17.
they do exist
i know
oh yeah
um
okay so then i need a motion
to pass with the members
i move out to pass with amen on
senate bill 313 with amendment 1791-h
okay thank you a second
seven nunez
representative nunes
uh seconds
okay let's uh any any discussion
sing no none okay uh when you're ready
mr clerk
call me first
okay the uh the bill is sb 313 the
amendment is 1791 h the motion is ought
to pass as amended we'll begin the roll
call vote with representative abrami yes
senator valerie yes
representative doucette yes
the clerk votes yes
welcome to ways and means representative
petuck
thank you sir
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury yes representative tudor yes
representative aaron
i'm sorry representative almi
yes representative ames yes
representative southworth yes
representative malloy
the honorable thomas c schomburg
you make my week yes
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo yes
representative hacken phillips yes
representative murphy yes
17.
okay the vote being 17 to nothing
the the
motion passes
and without objection beyond consent
calendar
okay so beyond consent
and representation will do the uh
the committee report thank you
uh i just uh work with certain nudist
and then yes i just wanted to clarify
that the the language there's other
languages going to be going on 330.
correct yeah we're going to talk about
that right now so representative i just
for um administrative purposes uh
the maker of the bill should be prepared
to defend it against people who don't
understand what we're doing
and i think they know everything i mean
the majority report that the senate
majority report is the committee okay
somebody takes it off the floor off
their consent
okay there's about 80 that might want to
do that all right thank you
so
all right we know who they are
so um
let's just before we go to
senate bill 379 which shouldn't take us
very long
uh
we've
um
i'm recommending that two of us be on
this
on 33 30 does everybody agree with that
i'd like to see one republican one
democrat
and then uh
i i increased their number to two i mean
i i don't think we should have two and
they they not have two
uh and then have one one
have a fifth that would be
picked by the
okay so we will leave it at that we
could do two two ways it means two edna
and one health and human services
end of one senator
no i won't but when we when they ask
because they always ask us who do we
want we'll we'll say that
so represent really
just
for consideration purposes i understand
um
and appreciate who most likely would be
assigned to that but uh
frankly edna does has a great deal of
knowledge about this and it's going to
take some splaining to do to quote
the great ricky ricardo
um
it would also seem to me that if they
had more people from edna and more
people from ways and means to
raise it up to seven it would be easier
to have a quorum present number one and
number two it would be
the
base of discussion would be spread out
over a larger number of group people so
that small
gatherings
could be explained as to why we're doing
this or the the justification for that
uh it just seems
to me that if you're going to have that
kind of a steady commission that that
would be um
a more better way to do it because you
would be able to
spread out the knowledge
rather than keep it compact with a
smaller group i
i i understand what you're saying but i
i'd have to check with her i don't i
don't want any i want to be
in agreement with the dna
she didn't seem like she wanted to add
even one more of her own people so
uh i don't want to go there i think five
would be a good number
to work with
huh
two and two right right
no we could do an outlaw mr remember the
senator won't show up
well like with the exception of a couple
yeah i shouldn't make it so broad
let's but to i just want to look at
something i don't know
this committee report uh is
an interim report due at the end of this
year but a final report next year so it
goes across elections
which is better because this is a really
complicated thing
and what happens if
is that
people just get reappointed
i've been on those that have gone across
election years
you if you're still here you could you
get reappointed generally
if not they pick some new people
all right i think we got an agreement on
this all right um um let's open hearing
on and um keane's here we're gonna have
after we get done with uh
with three uh senate bill 379
uh we're going to talk about i forget
the bill number now
um
yeah and we're gonna just have a little
discussion on what the uh the amendment
that they did to the bill
uh
in a minute so bear with us a second um
all right i'm going to open the um well
first off
it's a work session is anybody here to
testify on
on um
on 379. nobody had introduced a bill
yeah
i i spent most of the hour i was driving
down here talking with karen ebel
who on
is the head of the solid waste
committee whatever it's called
and
on
senator waters is in
committees frantically trying to deal
with our bills right now
and
wasn't planning on coming over because
neither of them understood what a work
session is
i explained it's what finance does but
i've tried to tell finance nobody
understands what a work session is and
they just don't get it
so
on they none of them
she's not
really available either but i think she
sent us
something that i was asking to be passed
out that
um
but
to the effect of well
several things um
one of them is that
the repeal on the existing surcharge of
out-of-state waste is against the
interstate commerce clause which i think
a lot of us understood
and it's been it was enacted long ago
and has been sitting there in the
background and they decided while they
were doing this they'd get rid of it
because the attorney general tells them
there's no way we can enforce it
um
it was
a surcharge for only
waste coming from out of state
vermont seems to have found a way to do
that actually but
but again for the committee that's not
that's not that's not in our domain
right it came to us because of this fund
but but it is uh the surcharge would
have been in
our domain
so that's the easy part of that uh the
solid waste management fund
they used to have a planning department
back when we had more money
in
des for solid waste it
was
defunded
years ago
and
now we're in solid waste crisis in the
state um
a number of people have brought forward
the idea that we ought to be
um
doing that again and they have managed
apparently to start
that but
uh
this
fund was
recommended by the solid waste group
and was the origin of this bill which
they amended first in the senate
to say
that
originally it just said that on this is
being re-established as i understand it
uh then they amended it to say oh
there's a 500 000 appropriation
got to finance in the senate and the
senate and finance took that out
because they were told by
on des that there are specific funds
coming from the federal government
i guess from the infrastructure
fund bill
on that they can apply for that will
allow them to fund this program
uh
at least for i don't know how many years
but
on
and the program itself
is used principally to make grants to
to new hampshire municipalities that are
struggling with this
problem
so um
that i think is about all that was in
that email which i don't know if we've
gotten yet
if i may that's exactly what i was going
to say there is an email here from
representative evil uh to our
legislative
oh to a legislative account to a
legislator she addresses the house ways
of means
yeah with a copy to it was that did that
come this morning yeah it's just now
yeah about oh okay yeah that's why i
didn't see him right she started working
on it around 9 30. all right
okay thank you and representative laurie
yes um reading this bill i don't see
where they make any reports about how
much money is received how much and what
is done with it they just receive it and
they spend it
but
it's up to them to receive it and spend
it
but they don't tell anybody what they're
receiving and what they're spending well
to apply for it receive it go to fiscal
to get it approved uh and it doesn't say
that
i believe that you will always have okay
you you're satisfied then
true
school and government report
we i think
we should know what's coming in for the
budget purposes
finance should understand
how they're spending
money
and then there just needs to be some
sort of check and balance to make sure
that
they're receiving money and spending
money and nobody's building a pool in
their backyard
well i think we need to know
we need to look at 149 m29
ii
to see
who gets that biennial report
and is that basically rule making
this particular
that should be specified in the law
anybody
here comment on that
nope
anybody here interested in waste
management and can contribute
sorry
all right
i mean the way i read this
is that
we're just gonna we're creating a fund
there's no state money going into the
fund it's it's there to accept federal
money
so i
i just said yeah nothing this is no big
deal but uh but
and final reading
uh
do
does everybody
who else shares representatives concern
that
we discovered this there is a report
but who does none of the question on the
table is who does that report go to
by annual report
the department and that the department
in this case the department of
environmental service i think they
oversee this yes correct yes
well yeah well no we're giving them the
authority to do that
now we have we have many funds that we
don't we don't vote on every dollar that
comes in and out of the
excuse me under our system
fiscal does a lot of these things
i had the honor of subbing on it for the
first time last a couple of weeks two
weeks ago
and uh
it really
you can understand a lot better if you
sit there through pre-fiscal and then
then there they do look at these things
on
and they ask questions it's not as good
as if it went through the legislative
process
but if everything went through the
legislative process i don't know
right if
we'd have anybody willing to fight can
someone uh
if you if you look at line 19 on page
two
the activities and finances of solid
waste manager fund as required by rsa
149 are cohen six
so that may
there's no rsa 149 created in there
in the bill
but line 17
should say where the biennial report
goes
so
149 am 29
roman 2.
is we're creating a line item that for
now will be blank to be determined
depending on federal funds or whatever
so we have that piece and then what
representative uhler is saying is once
we have that piece we want
accountability for the number right and
i think we will agree to that
um
representative
yeah
i was just going to say i have 149
hyphen m colon 29
in front of me and it it does not say to
whom the report goes
but to me that
i was going to look for
prior reports to see where they go but
they're public reports and
certainly available um
and uh
i really go back to what representative
abrami said i think that
this is a straightforward bill it
doesn't involve an appropriation of
money
it sets up a
a fund which apparently is needed for
the receipt and allocation of spending
of federal funding funds that are
available we all know solid fund
i mean solid waste
management is a big
problem these days and uh so i i
the policymakers
involved in this
say we need it and i think we should
just go along
yeah and this kid this came out of uh
environmental and agriculture 17 to
nothing as well
um another 17-nothing vote it was on a
consent calendar
um
i mean who who would you suggest
representati
that the report be sent to
i think as representative ames says is
that it's it is public it isn't like
it's not public it'll be public
reporting for themselves about whether
or not the rules that they wrote
the rules
did you turn on your microphone
sorry and i was stepping back thank you
when when you take a look at rsa 149
colon m
the
it
in there it says that they have
rule-making authority and that they have
to comply with the rules
but they get to determine whether they
comply with the rules and they can spend
the money for what they want
but but isn't that the case with every
one of these funds it's it's under the
jurisdiction of
well this specifically says are any
other uh
funds
meeting the their criteria which is
management of solid waste so i mean
but that's why i mean the rules are
going to go to jail car and
you would think that that kind of thing
would be challenged if if if they felt
that the rules were people are going to
challenge that
i i i okay does anybody else support
what
representative ruler is saying
are we complicating this too much
maybe we are
okay i don't see any other that think
they're going to jump and
represent this pillsbury
i would just simply say i find the whole
bill very mysterious
it doesn't say much
about what its intentions are
so
we take it as a matter of faith
well
yes
i think that the problem is that
environment and agriculture has been
dealing with this for
some time now and they put together a
massive study committee
that on is looking at the entire issue
of waste disposal in this state
on just last year i think that's
operating now
and which is i think it's a commission
and
on
and this is just a piece of it they
decided
that
they really need to be able to
or help organize the effort of local
municipalities who are struggling
with
if their transfer stations can send to
the next landfill because the landfill
is filling up is which is in our case a
real problem in our region
we keep on managing to extend
a few years at a time into the future
when we won't be able to do it anymore
and for a place in vermont was supposed
to take over from us and has closed it
down
so
they
this is going on
all over the state and there are ways
by reducing the waste that goes into the
landfill
by
reusing some of it for energy reusing
some of it
by recycling
that
that you can extend the use of those
landfills a long time
but
it takes some resources
for the municipalities that's what this
thing is
talking about it takes some guidance
from people who really know what they're
doing
on
in lebanon our landfill manager is
actually the guy that was head of
planning before they ran out of money
in the state level and so he's really
good but apparently they have two
good people that they've managed to find
funding for in des right now that are
are reviving planning
so that part of it they've managed to
take
care of in other committees
this part of it the dedicated fund would
be
to help provide resources to the towns
that
that on
need a bit of extra money to figure out
the recycling to figure out
any
conversions of part of the
of the waste stream to
productive uses like
we've just
built in
and
methane to
energy
component that we've been trying to
build for 10 years that we've finally
got going now
representative southworth and suburbs
and rory ah thank you there are some
details starting line 22 i think that's
the beginning um you know perhaps some
people would like more details but that
certainly gives a starting point for the
kind of things that would be covered
representative
yeah
directly to representative army um
the purpose of the fund is fine it's
perfect i mean i shouldn't say perfect
there's nothing that's perfect but it's
it's a good idea the quick the only
question that i have is
you have a requirement for
a report
to the agency that says that you have a
requirement for the report that the
agency
keeps
yeah it's a public record
but none of the people that are are
dealing with i mean the treasurer
doesn't
is just putting money into the fund
there's no oversight of the fund other
than
the entity that's writing its own rules
and then
receives a report saying it's complying
with its own rules and where they spent
the money so do you want to add do you
want to add a copy of the report goes to
the governor to the you know
the speaker of the house we've seen
those what do you want what do you want
the reason that would be fine and that's
what i suggested earlier that that's all
i'm suggesting is that uh that this
become
more available to
the the general public to to see what's
going on because you're dealing with a
substantial amount of fund and i really
don't like to see an agency running
itself and certifying to itself that it
did what it said it did
all right
yes representative
i don't really have any objection to
that i don't myself think it's necessary
but i certainly won't stand in the way
but i would
i've just also found the
2019 biennial report remember these are
biannual reports
uh on online is
at the website of ges uh it's
a solid 19 pages of uh
single space type that looks very
thorough and now they're going to have
to add to it
the uh
activities and finances
of the solid waste management fund and a
report on that
so
so it's there it's available
yeah
so there's one report for the entire des
i
i can't answer it that way because i
don't know what the other statutes say
they have to report on
but now they're going to have to report
on whatever that is plus
this this fund activity it's got solid
waste programs
uh congressional actions and court
rulings
oh all sorts of stuff right
right
yeah and so forth so thank you yeah i i
was
i just texted
karen abel uh waters
i could call him up apparently but
uh they're on the reports are online
like any agency reports there's also a
long-range solid waste plan also
available
so this isn't necessary
all right
all right i'm going to i'm going to say
let's start with this does anybody want
to amend this bill in some way
we're up against the clock too that's
the other problem you know do we have
we're going to have to sit around for a
couple hours waiting for for amendment
to come
i don't think anybody wants to
um but
how much coffee do we have
so
i'm just gonna say just show our hands
who just wants to move this bill right
now
okay well majority so i think we're
gonna do that mr chair
bad legislation comes out of haste but
i will not object
you know for this kind of thing
uh to me
to me a lot of this i mean we have we
have some faith in our uh
office of legislative services
when they draft these kind of bills i
mean this isn't the first fun build
they've seen
that and it'd be a big omission if they
thought they were you know omitting
something from the standard language but
anyway
so i'm i'm gonna uh any other any other
discussion uh i'd just like to add to
that that
i think actually putting it in the
in the biennial report of the department
is uh
is the best place we can because anybody
who's dealing with environmental
problems reads through that thing
from the outside we usually don't have
time but they do
all right so we're going to go into
executive session
uh i'll make the motion
uh
ought to pass on senate bill 379. i'll
second that mr chairman okay
schomburg seconds
okay um i think we did plenty of
discussing i i don't have anything
further to say does anyone else have
anything to say on this
okay i think we're ready for the vote
all right the uh the bill is senate bill
379 the motion is ought to pass we'll
begin the voting with chairman abrami
yes
representative vollery yes
clerk votes yes representative doucet
yes
representative nunes
representative pettuck
yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes
representative army
yes representative ames
yes representative southworth yes
representative malloy yeah the honorable
representative thomas c schaumburg yes
mr clerk representative tucker
oh sorry representative gomarlo yes
representative
yes representative murphy yes
okay the vote being 16
nothing
uh
so the the motion passes
out to pass and uh on consent calendar
without objection
no objection consent calendar
okay
all right
uh just one last thing is a brief
discussion on
most of the again
hb 1097 this relates to the
massachusetts yeah
if keane you want to come up as well if
you want to
add some
why don't you just refresh our memories
on what that which one that bill was and
then well we'll let keane go first and
then representative suppose where you
can
morning representatives keen mayweather
for the department of revenue
administration uh i'm here to provide an
update on house bill 1097
which is relative to the taxation of
income of new hampshire residents when
working remotely for an out of state
employer
this bill went through the senate ways
and means committee and they requested
for an amendment to
to the bill they did not
like the um they prefer not to have the
language that we added that the dra
added um
in sections two and three which
just says that uh none of these the
language of this bill shall impact the
uh application of the bpt and the bad
taxes
to that effect we redrafted the bill
and removed those two
subsections
and we basically what we did was to
refocus the bill language specifically
on the
employment employee employer employee
income and therefore
trying to avoid any sort of implications
to spread outside that scope of income
um i brought
a copy of the amended the senate amended
bill in case if
this is printed from the
gen court website okay yeah
that'd be great
the reason we're hearing this is that
they're
the senate's going to ask if we concur
on this or not so we need to just
understand it
if we don't concur you know we're
probably asking for a uh
a committee a conference but
but we're also going to hear from
representative spillsbury who spent a
lot of time with this and testified over
in the senate as well
um
how many did you bring
i brought 25 copies okay some somehow
they got jammed up somewhere
okay where the rest of them go
all right
the basic language of the bill remains
the same um i did not uh
did not
we did not amend uh or revise the uh
the
the purpose of the bill
uh the only thing we did was to just
put in the additional language
specifically focusing the bill towards
employer employee income
yeah is that
line where line 10
yes that's right
so line 9 onwards
okay
and uh you feel you feel comfortable
with this change
yes uh a few few members of the
department revenue
senior members of the department revenue
look through this and we're
we're comfortable we did not run this
through by the ag's office again so um
and i'm not sure that's necessary and
the uh
and the senate committee had actually
wanted to
obtain input from
attorney bill artinger
but i'm not sure if that
happened
okay
yeah we know a lot of us know bill argue
on this committee yeah so
all right
questions for
yeah
representative ames
uh first is a question to you and that
is timing on this consideration of this
this
will be coming back to
presumably we'll be coming back after
senate action which hasn't happened yet
right that's why we haven't gotten the
formal so it hasn't even gotten to that
point but at some point it's going to
come back to the house for concurrence
or non-concurrence and so forth right
so it sounds like we've got some time
and what i'd like to ask since uh
none of us have seen or else most of us
have not seen this
is to
have time to take it back and
look at what uh transpired before
and what we ended up with and then uh
make an informed decision after that
discuss and so forth right and i i can't
remember the dates now we're meeting
next week two days
probably the senate's voting as well so
when when do we have to have our concurs
not concurs i think the week the week
later right after that
right
so i'm trying to think of and i know
norm
represent major was planning on doing
some review estimating so we would
probably be together one more time
before we have to have our
do we want to commit a conference and i
don't want yeah so i that's why i was
concerned but i think there's a good
preview
of what's coming so i think we'll
you know just in case i was saying well
let's have this discussion so that
you know we don't have to come in just
to
discuss this but it sounds like if it's
a couple weeks out that we will be okay
yeah it's very good that we have this uh
we got time to look at it carefully and
be thoughtful about it so uh good
process okay any other questions of and
i want a representative well oh okay
there's
the senate oh they are they'll be voting
on thursday
right so we could
be facing it on the fifth
they're meeting on
this thursday the 28th
and so they'll probably be taking this
up
on
but
we
and we meet the fourth and fifth
but on
i think that you could just go to the
speaker and say we're not ready yet
can you please do this one on the 20 on
the 12th
right on the 12th right
right but you'd have to tell them oh no
no yeah absolutely we
absolutely
so
uh all right before we get to
representative pillsbury uh remember
generally yeah just uh for
representative spillsberry's uh
presentation uh regarding the
discussion that brought this up so i
don't have to ask the question again
um
was the purpose to eliminate
reference to specific sections of law to
make this more broad
uh without getting down into the weeds
about bet bpt and all that confusion
that's for a question for representative
spillsberry as he gets into his presence
okay thank you okay because i think he
can explain it better than i can so
representative pillsbury
thank you mr chairman explain what
happened at the same time sure quite a
bit has been said so i'll try not to be
redundant but uh very simply
um house ways and means hearing
uh i thought was very well focused uh
both representative ames and i testified
as did king
i think the members
very quickly focused on the clutter
and the distraction
that was created in the bill by the
references of disclaimers to the bpt and
the bet so they asked the question
whether we would object to having those
eliminated and what
what would we suggest
if they were to be eliminated
and i believe it's correct speaking for
representative ames that we both said
yes we would prefer to see those
provisions removed
and that
what would be necessary is simply to
ensure
that words were chosen in the first
paragraph that were specific enough to
clarify exactly what income the bill
does apply to then there would be no
reason to state what
in what taxes the bill does not relate
to
so the language
that keen then keem took on the task
at senator guida's request
and
he put in the phrase nine and ten
income from employer employee
relationships such as wage income salary
income or other employee compensation
earned or received by residents
and i'm very pleased with this i think
this is excellent
also
as i had committed to the committee that
i would work with the senate i brought
to their attention the suggestion that i
believe representative hillary and ames
had both made
that the word
may
in line 12
be changed to shall so those are the
only two changes to the bill it's the
deletion of the second and third
paragraphs that essentially became
surplusage
by a more careful statement of what
incomes applied
i would say that the uh
senate ways and commit the wins
senate ways and means committee approved
this 5-0 and has reported it for the
senate consent calendar
okay very good
representatives you want anything to
that
given that you you did testify i did
testify i had to leave
i think this was where i had to leave
immediately after so i didn't i wasn't
there for
the ensuing discussion
uh so uh i simply presented what you'd
already heard uh you know
all right so
okay
so we'll have a week or two to digest
that's great yeah and uh and i think i
thank uh representative spillsbury and
kane for
uh pursuing this
okay
so any any other comments questions
about this okay
so you'll be hearing about this one more
time when we get back together
yes one more time
okay
so any other business anybody wants to
bring up
oh representative almighty
just can we try to get a date with
representative major
about which day we would be looking at
revenue estimates yeah i'll do that
early may so that
uh we can all try to be here
right um
my plan is to call representative major
this afternoon to talk he's probably
listening right now by the way
this the last couple hours so
i don't know
yeah yeah yeah
all right nothing
no other business oh well see you next
week everybody and on the floor bye bye
yes i'll relay that to to represent
major thank you
you